the surgeongeneral orel hershiser World
Series champs I young winter dodger
broadcaster aural good to visit with you
again how are you good morning good
morning how's life life is good I
haven't built the wing for any Emmys yet
but I don't have as many as you okay how
big is your trophy room in your house
it's my office and I would not even have
it but other people want to see the
stuff so we just have it there for them
okay what do you have in there that
might surprise me Arnold Palmer putter
from when he won a tournament that I got
from Payne Stewart it was a really close
friend of mine um some sentimental stuff
like that some from the 59 scoreless but
it was really used when my mom my boys
were growing up that it was used for
like when the Little League teams came
over and stuff I would kind of like sit
them all down on like on the floor and
hey guys let's let's look around the
room and let's talk and let's get
inspired and so it was more for the kids
and the cocktail parties it wasn't
really for me I kind of like wish it
wasn't even there sometimes you got this
song award there yeah it's there but
that wouldn't surprise you I guess no I
was trying to think what would surprise
you
I'm there's there's more family stuff
there really than the trophies you know
kind of in and about people look and see
the song or if you they see things that
are that have happened but they don't
they don't always see like the picture
of me and my sons like on the field at
Dodger Stadium or me with my son Jordan
in Cleveland in The Times Square area
when you know we've we lost in the World
Series but they still had a parade for
us so stuff like that what do you have
memorabilia wised from the 59 scoreless
inning streak not much I really don't I
don't have much I sold the baseball and
your buddy bought it he bought yeah
Keith bought it yeah he bought it for
about eight thousand bucks I've been
starting I've been selling my
memorabilia for the last four or five
seven years
off and on you know smaller stuff
because I don't want to leave it to my
kids and just have a bunch of stuff so
I'm like I'd rather sell it and Keith
Keith bought it and he's a collector of
baseball's that are kind of off the
beaten path baseball's he doesn't like
go for the ultimate one yeah but he'll
he finds he finds ones that he thinks
are gonna be special to him or special
and you know down the road so yeah how
do you explain that scoreless streak uh
God came down in my body and wanted to
pitch I guess it all comes together
especially for a guy that especially for
a guy that didn't strike out a lot of
people yeah so when you know it's one
thing to do something like that that's
kind of off the beaten path as far as
everybody I don't know how do you
explain it it's 30 years and you don't
keep the ball down have good defense
behind you have a team that's not score
a lot of runs so every run is really
important so you know you give a full
deed off double and all of a sudden you
can't let that run get in you can't
trade it out for a run you know we were
we were not a high scoring team which
probably helped if all of a sudden in
one of those starts I get a six seven
nothing lead and early in the game all
of a sudden it's like you know we just
need to get this and get this over with
and win games oh there's a double Oh big
deal I'll just you know I'll get a
groundout oh the guy would go over I'll
get a fly out all the guys scores but
you know we were we weren't scoring much
and we were in a race and so every pitch
every run mattered and it happened to
work out it was the toughest guy you
face during that streak well as far as
getting getting hits Tony Gwynn you know
Tony Gwynn had a steering wheel on his
bat I mean it was unbelievable when he
put the ball in play it found the hole
well you don't hear too many guys who
have a steering wheel and they're bad
but like Rod Carew
probably had a steering wheel on his bad
as well like certain guys could just
like tilt it a little bit to the left
and tilt it a little bit to the right
and just flare and flick it right yeah
everything's analyzed to density on the
air and on the radio or whatever but
yeah back to then those guys it would be
amazing if all of a sudden we had the
data of where they hit it would where
all of a sudden there be would there be
ground balls if those guys didn't get
through the infield because you know all
of a sudden you know infielders are
moved around it's really it's a
completely different game nowadays as
far as defense and pit filming
information and it's it's it's really
amazing how the game is evolved but also
and we're talking to orel hershiser the
Dodger broadcaster World Series champ
nationally siyoung winner but I'm
wondering what the scouts would say what
if they looked at you because you
weren't you weren't considered a hard
thrower right they would look at you and
go oh gosh I don't what do we do with
this guy you know
is he is he gonna be a middle relief guy
you did keep it down but you weren't
overpowering people you were just a
great pitcher yeah it's a little
different I mean the ultimate the
ultimate pitcher for without velocity
would be probably Greg Maddux or Tom
Glavine John Smoltz of that era would
definitely pitched nowadays because he
could overpower Ewing at an unbelievable
slider and he was a big strong guy you
know are the guys that we located and
have movement I think I think we pitch
and I think we do well I just think yeah
you're right it would might have been a
little her road to all of a sudden get
the ball and keep the ball so I don't
know I don't know you know I've I've
talked to Andrew Friedman our president
of a sloppy and we do went toe to toe
early on with all the data and all the
stuff and he said you know well I'd have
been better and I go how I had been
better and he goes you you could locate
we would have figured it out you know
you we would have shown you places where
you can throw the ball and you would
have got people out more consistent
basis and I'm probably I'm thinking to
myself you know what he's probably right
but it's going to be odd because I
probably would have to change
where I went strength against strength
against a lot of people it was more you
know sync relay sync releasing where you
know it's coming but here it comes and
it's gonna be hard to hit where I
probably would have thrown more forcing
fastballs if I would have the data
because on the eye test Darryl
Strawberry probably tells you you need
to you needed you need to jam him but
but do I really want to go there because
there's doubles and homeruns there and
so we didn't know exactly it was it was
just like okay I've seen video of them
oh is it last week hit a home run on
this pitch you know can I really get it
in there well nowadays you know if you
get it in there or not you know if you
know I test wise that's a scary position
to throw the ball to him and I've seen
him hit it but you know exactly now that
that is a good pitch no matter how odd
it seems to throw it there or you have
facts and with the facts and the ability
to locate all of a sudden it's a new
game it's a new game instead of like
maybe it's like for sure you can go
there what about Kershaw if he was
pitching in the 70s and 80s he'd be
unbelievable and any generation matters
picture that ever lives
no that's the best picture that ever
lived he's ridiculous weight and you
know what you think he's the best ever
I really do I really do yeah he's I mean
statistically that's that's easy to
prove I test it's not as easy to prove
because people have people's eyes are
swayed by when they watched and what
they saw and when it happened and you
know some people will say ok he hasn't
won a World Championship so he can't be
the best ever well I I don't believe
that that the marathon the marathon he
is won the sprint at the end of the
season he has not there have been others
that have been better record wise but
he's the best ever but is it best stuff
no it's well boy that's it that's a
great question I know it's not that
stuff no it's it's best ever on a
consistent basis will the winner stuff
execution
passion to execute and when he needs to
make a pitch make the pitch and now
we're seeing a completely different
Clayton Kershaw and so he is just
ridiculously sold out to winning and not
having an ego on how to win or how he's
gonna go about it
he doesn't have an ego about his stuff
like there's guys that were like this is
who I am and apply myself the situation
and I'm going to continue to do that and
you when they start hitting me they have
their head in the sand
Clayton Kershaw is not that he he's a
strategist now he's a winner he
understands the game he understands his
opponent he understands now what his
stuff and how to apply it and continues
to win and be dominant how do you assess
this team now certainly with what
they've done here in the last month they
they weren't as trustworthy as they are
now they're very very deep but I think
the team's gonna change when we get to
the playoffs I think the team you know
when you go from a 38 40 man roster
whatever we're playing with right now
that back down to 25 you're going to all
of a sudden not be the same team I but I
think that everybody is focused and
they're competing to be on that roster
and it's one thing to win the division
which I think they're going to do but
it's another thing to win the world
championship and I think that everybody
is focused on that goal and that goal is
getting clearer and clearer with the
deeper we get into the season now with
only nine games it's it's it's a team
that everybody is on the same page even
if is I'm only going to get two at-bats
and I'm going to start against the lefty
but you know I'm not starting against a
righty but I might be in there the six
or I might be in there for defense I'm
gonna be pitching probably only gonna
get a batter
I would love to pitch an inning or two I
used to be a starter and I'm or a lever
this is it's a team of maybe the best
roster and all the baseball but you know
they they have have sold out now to the
goal of doing the team thing it's not
about oh there's 200 possible at-bats
less than a year for me and I wish I
would get them but I'm only going
one hundred over because we're tuning
this team this team is locked in on the
goal of winning hope you have a great
weekend their oral with the bobblehead
doll and certainly a lot of fond
memories there and it's great to catch
up with you it's good to hear from you i
watch your show and I listen to yourself
and it's a lot of fun I learn a lot
thank you we appreciate it oral well
love to have you on again all right you
later that's orel hershiser for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]